- Yo, D, what up?
- Yo, Melo, what's up, man?
- You ever seen a female quarterback in Hawaii?
- She's the starting quarterback for that high school in Honolulu, right?
- She's legit. And she's got a cannon.
I'mma send you the details
and let you know. I'll keep you posted.
- Yeah, man, I'm game.
- Let's do this.
- High school football in Hawaii—sounds nice.
But for Alexandria Buchanan, it's not just another day in paradise.
Last season, she earned the title of only
female starting varsity QB in Hawaii.
No wonder she went viral.
She breaks her team's four-year losing streak, and now she's fighting for her job.
- Football is a male-dominant sport. Everybody knows that.
- She's, um, fought for everything that she's earned. Nothing's been given to her.
- People always say, like, especially in comments
on articles or whatever, like, "People aren't gonna hit her,"
"They're gonna look like the bad guy, cuz it's a girl,"
like, "They're just gonna let her go."
In the stands, people are saying things
like, "Get her out," or "Get the other guy in" or "Why is she starting?"
Football is a contact sport. I'm expecting to get hit. I'm not in flag football anymore.
You can't say that just because I'm a girl people will take it lightly.
And it's just frustrating because I get hit. [Laughing]
I get hit a lot
and I can take it.
- Throwing has always been fun for me. That's what I really enjoy doing.
Nice.
Ooh. Good catch!
It's hard for people to understand, like, a girl taking that position.
Hut, hut.
I know I work hard, and football is something I'm really passionate about.
You have to remember to do your job.
And I don't want people to think just because I'm a girl they have to stop doing that.
♪♪♪ Eager eyes are watching, hearts are beating fast.
For McKinley's honor, FIGHT, team, to the last. ♪♪♪
- Well, I think it's always been about the team.
I want to make sure these kids understand that, you know?
I mean, not one person can carry the team in a game situation.
- No matter how bad or good I'm doing, they've stuck it out with me.
- I love how we can look at each other as actual brothers and sisters.
- We're all, like, close to each other. We don't really bring anyone down.
- I really feel like they're my second family. That's just how a team should always be.
My first game, I just went in for a couple plays, and I got hit.
And I got up, and I was like, "Oh, that's not too bad. Like, I can handle this."
That first play went fine. All the other plays went fine.
And then after that I just started building up confidence that I needed.
[Cheering]
That's when they put me at starting, like, for the JV team.
I was completing my passes, I was making the right reads for the most part.
- And she came back one day, and
she said, "My coach wants to talk to you." [Laughing] That's what she said.
He's like, "You know, Mr. Buchanan," he said.  "you know your daughter
has something that I don't think anybody even understands yet.
I want her to come on the varsity football team."
- For me, it really doesn't matter. I think if you have a passion
to want to do something, then good for you.
More so if you're a female playing a male-dominant sport, right?
- She took the field. Everybody erupted.
And, you know, a few plays later, she made history.
- History was made as McKinley's Alexandria Buchanan
became the first-ever female to start at quarterback in a
Hawaii varsity football game, tossing the first female touchdown ever.
South Pacific Bureau, let's hear it for Alexandria.
- That prompted a landslide of national recognition.
- A game-changer in every sense for the Tigers.
- It was a really close game, as well. We lost by one point, and that
was the first time we've lost by that little in years.
So everyone's already excited about that. The following Monday was insane.
Like, everyone's just coming up to us and congratulating us.
My phone is blowing up with messages and stuff from people that I don't even know.
That really pushed me cuz I saw, like, people are noticing what I'm doing.
So I have to play not only for myself but for my team.
Cuz they're counting on me as well.
- Alex made high school football history.
But let's be real: Nobody tries to go viral.
Sometimes you just make history because you're you
- I never saw it as a big deal. I see so many quarterbacks on this island
doing that over and over and over and over, and I just feel bad because
they're putting in the work. My boys are putting in the work on my team, and
they are not getting all of this attention as well.
All of the pressure does get to me sometimes.
I'd say I had a lot more challenges this year than last year.
Not only is it my second year playing for the varsity level, but
I'm also getting all of this attention. People notice me now.
- She's been struggling since our first game.
- Things have gotten tough. And I know it hasn't been easy for them.
- She's thrown a number of picks, returned for, uh, touchdowns the other way.
Anytime you're not doing well, you know, it's interesting
how people will jump off the bandwagon.
- Yeah, there's a lot of talking, but you just let that go through. You just focus on us.
- If someone's, like, hating on me or whatever, saying, like, "You don't deserve this.
You don't deserve that attention and stuff," I sort of agree with them, so
I don't really take it to heart, which helps, you know?
Yeah.
- I figure Alex and the team could use some home-field advantage.
Since the L.A. Clippers were in town, I asked Tobias Harris and one of the only
female coaches in the NBA, Natalie Nakase, to stop by and show some love.
What’s up, y’all? What’s good? How you doin’?
- Hi, I'm Natalie.
- Nice to meet you.
- Y'all want to run a route?
- Yeah
- You all about to see. What type of arm you got?
- Accurate. I'd say 20 to 30?
- Ooh. That's pretty good. That's really good.
- Hut. Hut.
- Ohh!
[Laughing]
- Oh, catch that! Eh!
- When's your guys' next game?
- Um, Friday.
- OK. You're seriously an inspiration.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, I'm learning from you. So whatever you do out there, I'm
just gonna visualize it. These guys nice to you? They're respectful?
- Mhmm.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- If you have a problem, just let me know.
- When I'm not around, I really hope that they don't think anything negative.
They could just be putting up a front, I guess, but I really, genuinely
think they have faith in me and they trust me.
On the field, I'm supposed to say what you're doing right, what
you're doing wrong. And I expect them to do the same for me.
I'm not just trying to boss them around.
Alexandria Buchanan is a real quarterback.
This girl is calling all the shots
and she's not asking for your permission.
They knew it was gonna be a play-action play cuz
that's what we usually run on a two-point conversion.
One of the guys read it early. He caught up to me and just sacked me.
There was nothing I could do about it.
I got up, and I thought I was fine. My coach goes to touch
me, like, "Good job," and I flinched, like really badly.
And he's like, "Oh. Does your shoulder hurt?" And I was like, "Yeah."
I was out for the rest of the game. I couldn't do anything to help them.
I felt bad because I felt like I let them down. They were counting on me.
I'm the starting quarterback. I should be there.
Like, I'm the one getting all these reps and working on these plays
just so I can help them do their jobs.
In that moment especially, I felt like I let them down. And it was hard for me.
I let my boys down.
- Broken clavicle. So we're going to the hospital after this, but she wants
to watch the rest of the game. That's how she is.
- I'm definitely coming back next season.
I don't know how my parents feel about it yet, but I will definitely be back.
Hopefully stronger and better than ever. To show everybody what a girl can do.
I've learned so much and I've got to meet so many great people because of it.
I wouldn't change this opportunity for the world.
- Drew Brees couldn't make it to Hawaii.
He was busy breaking records of his own. So I called in a favor.
Because everyone deserves a biggest fan.
- Hey, this is Drew Brees with the New Orleans Saints.
- Oh my God. Hi.
- How you doin?
- Good.
- How you feeling? I see you've got the sling on.
- Yeah. I broke my collarbone.
- Oh, no! Just in this past game?
- Yeah, this past one.
- I can tell you this. I've had five surgeries in my life, and all of them were from football.
- Aww
- So sometimes that happens, right?
- Yeah.
- But you will come back stronger than ever.
I’m—I was so pumped to hear about your story. It's unbelievable.
- Thank you so much.
- Let's talk X's and O's.
- Do you like being under center with the play action and throwin' it deep?
Or do you like being in the shotgun? What do you prefer?
- I like shotgun.
- Yeah.
- If it's, like, a shorter pass, I like play action, though.
- OK. So you hand the ball off, you run option, and then
you'll do play action off of that, right?
- Yeah.
- So next year's the year.
- Yeah, hopefully. [Laughing]
- Good for you guys. I admire everything that you've accomplished thus far
and just know that you're gonna come back stronger from this injury, and,
um, next year you're gonna accomplish great things.
- Thank you so much.
- All right, Alexandria. Great talking to you.
- Great talking to you too.
- Best of luck. We're gonna talk again, OK?
- OK!
- All right, I'll see ya.
- Bye.
- Bye bye.
- Oh my God. [laughing] Oh my God.
I think I'm gonna cry.
That's so cool.
I never thought I'd be able to, like, talk to him.
I've been watching him ever since I was, like, really, really little.
So it's really unreal, you know? Like, you never think, like—not at school
in the middle of a school day, you know,—that you're just gonna
Facetime Drew Brees just one day.
- Hi, I broke my collarbone.
- Noooo.
[Laughing]
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Dang. How'd y'all do?
- We did OK.
- You did OK?
- Yeah.
- How long you out for?
- Four to six weeks.
- Ohhh.
- So I'm out for the season.
- Dang.
- Yeah. But I'll be back next season.
- All right. For sure.
- Yeah.
- Good to have you here.
- You're tougher than me. See, I was a really good flag football player.
[Laughing]
Then I played tackle, and when they
hit me, I said, "I don’t—I'm gonna go play basketball. I thought it was safer."
- I was talking with Natalie yesterday, and she said if we have the opportunity to
inspire other people that want to be in our position, then we definitely should.
- You're doing such a powerful thing.
- Thank you.
- And I hope you know that.
My only thing is just make sure you give back to the next generation.
- Yeah, of course, always.
- You know, motivate girls—
- Yeah.
- And, you know, have an open, like, voice to them. If they need you,
make sure, you know, just make sure you talk to them.
Because that’s—I feel like our responsibility. If we want to do something
that no one's ever done before, why not help somebody next, you know?
- Yeah, definitely.
- This is Carmelo Anthony. Thanks for watching.
To meet more heroes, go to breal.bleacherreport.com.